introducing dr. Penrose today there's
one of our faculty professor of physics
co-director of the Clark center and yeah
that's one of the great highlights of my
life was getting Sir Roger Penrose to
give me the capstone blurb on the back
of my book and that is in no doubt
responsible for its success although I
told him he gets none of the royalties
so of course I don't get that much in
life but anyway today yes as the mark
said it is the last day of final exams
which means we will have a final exam
after this for basic algebra so Roger is
been kind enough no he would he would be
that would be devastating I would not
want to take one of Sir Rogers final
exams but we're honored to have him here
he is nothing less than the most one of
the most brilliant polymaths that I've
ever had the opportunity and pleasure to
me his work influenced me and a whole
generation of physicists and popular
authors his his latest book faith fads
and fallacies and fantasy in physics is
is really just another epochal book in
the annals of physics writing for them
for the general public but also he can
write for a physicist audience as well
and his research is likely taken him in
a direction that is intersecting
literally with the research that I get
to conduct so things have come full
circle my greatest hero as an author as
a child growing up and being able to
read his books as things that he is the
most distinguished physicist in the
world I'll give you a brief history of
his time so far on earth and he has many
more discoveries yet to come he is the
emeritus raus ball professor of
mathematics at the University of Oxford
where he's federated with some of the
greatest minds in 20th and 21st century
physics and hopefully 26
his contributions range everything from
quantum mechanics foundations of gravity
his fundamental foundational work was
Stephen Hawking the late great Stephen
Hawking on black hole singularities
really set the directions for many
careers of my colleagues and theoretical
physics and mathematics but for the
minute he is an artist and he has the
soul of an artist to think which he
inherited from his late father Lionel
which really led to some of the most
profound things I was pointing out I
gave a colloquium at Pomona College in
Pomona last week and on their physics
and mathematics building they've got a
whole wall with Penrose tilings on it
and so there's some delightful - to see
that in you know even in person and soon
be a new new exhibit featuring these
these Penrose tilings at the San
Francisco Tencent terminal which is
coming in a hopefully in a year or so
already that's already there okay
they've closed it down some of the tiles
were crooked they said why doesn't this
repeat periodically so today of course
Sir Roger dinner many times we always
arrange the weather to be exactly
replicating that of Oxford England
cumson so it's a little chilly but
that's the way he likes it
and so the light to be here in the
sumptuous tots hall building brand new
building and it couldn't be a more
wonderful location for him to give a
discussion about a new conjecture for
chvotkin it was generating a tremendous
amount of exciting my field of cosmology
and beyond perhaps even to those
interested in communicating or receiving
communications from extraterrestrial
civilizations and and certainly with
regard to the cosmos only that is really
creating a lot of breakthroughs in
modern physics today so it's a delight
and a pleasure to welcome one of my
heroes and mentors back to UCSD for this
delightful lecture about evidence for
Hocking points on the cosmic microwave
background sky
[Applause]
thank you very much for that thank you
very much for that that we've Kristin
talking points know if you know about
cosmology you'll probably won't know
what they are because they're not in
cosmology as yet hope this we will see
when they are there it is still talking
of course as you guessed first I'm gonna
start this talk like at work making not
so long ago here before but I am so
rational through it in great speed but
still let me start with this is a
picture of the universe
it's a space-time picture but it's I
can't put all the four dimensions
together so you have to throw away to
the space dimensions and time is going
up the page so you have to think that at
any moment of time if I can say that you
have a section through this which
progresses up like that we're somewhere
I'm quite sure exactly where you might
ask what all the frilly stuff is doing
at the back that is no I don't want to
prejudice the issue mister whether the
universe actually closes that especially
or keeps on going what I want to say it
doesn't make
because it's not this is
[Laughter]
some people might complain about this
picture because I don't seem to have
represented this thing called inflation
inflation is something which is in the
picture is because it was to scale you
wouldn't see it okay so what you see if
inflation is there it's very similar to
what's happening already you see this
sort of exponential expansion is it's
for this has a role to play and what I
want to say because if you don't believe
it you have to have something else which
does the things for good things
one of the things that people claim for
inflation is that it sort of smoothes
out the universe the universe might be
over irregular in this inflation which
is completely flat that's the idea if
you think about solving equations in the
other way so universe in which it
doesn't really make any difference if
you put in whether think all the info
time field which is supposed to be
responsible for inflation if you put
that in there doesn't make any
difference in this picture that's
exactly what happens so since those
equations also work backwards in time
why wasn't the beginning like that it's
going to feature strongly and what I
want to say that the beginning was not
like that if it was like that and just
putting inflation in simply doesn't do
it you need something else and that's
the sort of thing before getting to that
what I want to do is repeat this picture
has two awkwardness is about it one is
you
Big Bang EMS if you could stretch it out
like a magnifying glass or something the
other thing is it keeps going on ethics
which can represent a certain type of
plane geometry it's called the
hyperbolic plane don't worry too much
about that but the point about this
representations is that the infinity of
that geometry is represented by a nice
boundary and you see these fish or
whatever they are they are represented
in such a way it's what's called a
conformal representation so that even
though the fish look as though they get
smaller towards the edge they're
supposed to as far as the picture
concerned they're the same size the ones
in the middle but then the
representation squashes them but it does
it in a nicer tropic way so this is much
squashing that way it's that way and you
can see particularly than the eyes fish
remain circles no matter how close to
the edge you get so these fish don't
know where they are the geometry is
completely uniform but with this
representation could squash down
infinity in this conformal way as I say
isentropic this is my discussing as much
as that and angles say the angles on the
wings of interbeing for these things on
the page the angles are exactly the same
where it no matter how close to the edge
you are so this is a thing to bear in
mind
see in this conformal way and that's a
very convenient trick to use so I'm
gonna use that trick and I'm also gonna
use another trick which is the opposite
trick I'm going to squash bang I'm
squatting down infinity and I'm gonna
stretch that they get right now both of
them in this conformal way so squashing
in both directions it's the same amount
and it so happens that you can squash
infinity down just like in the Escher
picture that's the Infinity there and
the opposite trick is to stretch out the
Big Bang now I want to say a little bit
more about this stretching let me say
that there are two is squashing down the
Infinity and stretching out the Big Bang
have a different logical status
completely and I'll say something about
that you see provided that you have
future you can this Universal this trick
of squashing affinity down is it's very
very general there's a theorem due to
helmet-free Greek we showed us that
under those circumstances no matter how
much wiggling it does you can squash it
down and nice boundary however the big
band is completely the opposite it's
only a very very special initial space
can be stretched out just completely
beginning so you can imagine both tricks
being done and you can certainly do this
on all the stand and cosmology is what I
call them for even robertson-walker de
mettre cosmologies they're very really
formed and you can do both tricks and
that's not a problem but you see the
logical spaces is very different because
in the general case of going backwards
into the Big Bang you get the sort of
mess which I was just showing you before
general Big Bang is right and so here's
what I rotate my I have the picture this
way around to show you what a general
collapse would look like if that also
tells you what a general Big Bang
and the argument is no matter how hard
should be in Patong field you put in it
does fleshing out inflation only works
if you start pretty well close to that
anyway if you have a mess like this it
doesn't go in for you so this is he
pointed what I want to say and I'll come
back to that in a moment but before
doing that let me say a bit more about
these conformal maps you see in the
geometry you see you stretch and squash
okay space-time geometry and space-time
geometry won't take it away it's correct
that you don't see anything you see okay
let me describe these pictures here
these are called like Hertz and or now
cones I supposedly correct terminology
but they tell you most of the structure
of the space-time you see in general
relativity you've got a notion of a
metric and that metric tells you the
scale of things in the different
directions but the key thing about it is
it tells me where the light coming now
this is you have to imagine say that
there's a flash of light here then that
flash black was spread out future and if
you could imagine that there was a flash
of light coming in was focusing on that
point then that would trace up the both
parts of the light cone the future light
cone in the past like the sections
through this as time progresses because
I throw it away one dimension here but
you have to measure the sections through
it they look like circles but they would
really miss fierce and that's air is
increasing with the speed of light and
that where those like homes are is
formal geometry
so I have a picture here of multiply
cones and they turning the light ray
with zip along the history of that Ray
would be a line which is always tension
to the light cones whereas the massive
particle its history this history would
always be something within the cone so
it's real constrained to be within the
speed of light but you can imagine these
comes the light cones are all tipped
over to such such a degrees the signal
inside here can't get out it falls in
was singular inside a black hole this is
the matter in the early stage collapsing
and forming this black hole so this this
is a picture of a spacetime in which you
know where all the light comes up now
you see that is as I said most of the
geometry it's not it at every point in
space-time you know everything called
the metric which is determined by ten
numbers it has the metric is things like
OGG a video game your JK or something
and that has ten numbers to characterize
it a nine of those numbers or more
accurately the nine independent ratios
of those ten numbers are what tell you
the conformal geometry so what they
really tell you here is where the light
cone is so the light cone is makes
basically nine out of ten the remaining
number as given by these surfaces here
which represent the ticks of Cox
so I'll imagine you have two identical
clocks here zipping close to each other
through that point different speeds and
these are the ticks where the clocks if
they're identical clocks just take
second take them take and so on and the
clocks coming out on the other side so
these services
tell you the scale and that gives you
the ten components now it's useful to
separate this out because certain things
in physics only care about the nine let
me tell you something about the scaling
of these c1c general relativity which is
on some stereo gravity you bent on
curved space-time itself it's now an
extremely well tested theory and the
test depends on having very very precise
clocks now you see why do we have such
precise clocks in nature well they
really come about because of the two
most fundamental equations of 20th
century physics one of them of course is
equals MC squared which shows you that
well C is a constant so telling us of
energy that's the E and the M is the
mass so energy and mass are equivalent
related just by the constants we know
the other formula is the one due to Max
plan and that it's a little bit early in
fact Max Planck's formula state tell you
e equals H nu or HF I'm not sure what
people call frequency these days and
then it's just being nearly this Greek
letter F if you like the energy and the
frequency equivalent the H is again
constant if you take that away that's an
absolute constant the energy and the
frequency are equivalent so if you put
the two for me together that tells you
the mass and frequency are equivalent so
if you have a particle now here's the
world and this particle that particle
naturally has a frequency which is
proportional to its so here we have a
stable particle suppose it's a stable
particle like an electron or something
like that that electron is an extremely
good clock clock because it really
depends on these very very basic
equations but then electron ticks away
has a frequency which is naturally
associated with that mass now of course
it doesn't make a very good clock in
practice because
crickets is much too high I've scaled
them and you have to get everything away
which there's nothing one particle
wouldn't do but nevertheless that's why
we have such good classes because it's
fundamental formula physics today we
have quarks which is so precise that you
can even measure they difference
incorporates here it will be slightly
different you cannot measure things like
that with a very very small separation
so it's extremely impressive what you
can do with clocks the meter rule in
Paris you wouldn't use it anymore
you reduce the definition of a meter in
terms of black seconds and so on so
that's ways define now okay so that's
them hard what I want to say the other
part I would say is that some things
don't care about these surfaces here
they just care about the light cones and
the most obvious thing is light photons
in fact Maxwell's equations we famous
equation of James Clerk Maxwell when you
showed how to unite electricity
magnetism and light showed that light
can be understood as a a way which is
just electric and magnetic fields
propagating themselves through space and
those equations are completely invariant
under these conformal standings so if
you imagine I mean this is just the two
that she'll pictured and the convention
squashing in some places as long as the
squashing and stretching is the same in
two directions so he took the squashing
in time is the same as squashing in
space then the Maxwell equations are
completely insensitive to that I think
squashing and stretching if they're
conformally invariant so that's an
example of something which is conformal
in there but it's much broader than that
basically anything which doesn't involve
mass if you don't have mass then you
don't need to know these things the
physics of no mass if you like this
the physics of black cards now in fact
most of the equations of physics the and
Mills equations which govern the way we
can strong forces behave if you didn't
have the mass term in there you just
look at them as classical equations they
again also completely insensitive to the
scale now what things are sensitive to
the scale well as I said mass but the
opposite and that is gravity because
gravity is the source of gravity is
Einstein's theory now a star theory has
a kind of love/hate relationship to two
conformal Maps saying that you just make
this point that you see some of physics
let's say the massless physics just
needs to light cones but massive physics
if you want to do a sandwich probably
won't talk about massive particles
something massive physics needs to know
the scalings
so massless physics is good for that and
if people massed in in one way or the
other then you need to know the scaling
so that's like a key point I want to
make you know I mentioned that in the
remote future this picture of squatching
and stretching the future boundary here
it's nothing which works fine if you
don't have any mass now where is most of
the mass in the universe was going to go
well it's a lot of mass in our galaxy
and then we have in our center of our
galaxy the hole which is about four
million times the mass of the Sun so
there's quite a bit of mass because
that's not nearly there total mass of
the galaxies hello it's a small fraction
that black hole will go on drinking
stars and eating stars whatever right
technologies and well and the other
thing is going to happen is that black
hole that we have
well let me I was going to talk about
black holes colliding which is anyway
black holes and the classify galaxies
will start to GARP each other down and
you'll end up with one whopping black
hole in the center escaping so you have
to bear in mind that a huge proportion
of what goes on
Rustom galaxies well eventually it's all
about the black holes but then you've
got these whacking great black holes
around and what you do with them well
Hawking tells you what to do with them
and here we have hawking evaporation you
see a black hole according to Stephen
Hawking and I think he's absolutely
correct
the so they're not exactly black it's
the way he said it
they have a slight glow about well you
have to think of the hottest ones are
the smallest ones there's more black
holes in the hot ones um are they well
they are the mass of something maybe a
few times the mass of the Sun and how
hard are they when you have to think in
terms of the coldest temperature ever
made on yeah well it's somewhere around
there so the bigger ones are much much
colder so how long are they gonna be
around you some universe expanding
expanding expanding as it expands it
gets colder and colder and eventually it
against colder than the black holes even
the very biggest ones and then those
ones start to evaporate they radiate
away and the energy the mass energy of
the hole starts to shrink the hole
shrinks get smaller and smaller
eventually disappears with a pot I'm
calling you the pot because although at
the end you have some nasty stuff okay
it's pretty well apart from point of
view of general astrophysics how long is
that gonna take
well for the biggest ones of all
something like the Google of years I
mean by Google one followed by a hundred
zeros and that number of years that sort
of range of years is this a lot of time
you're gonna have to wait before these
black holes finally disappear this was
one of the things that made me worry
about well this isn't anything about
universe will be boring and okay when
you've got nothing left in black holes
that's pretty boring yes that's really
boring that's really really really
boring is the universe after that's
happened
and I thought well I mean just an
emotional argument I have to admit but
then by this university the main things
that are round will be photons and
photons well it's down hard the Borah
photography partly because photons have
experiences yes they don't want
experience if I can use they were
passage of time this is a factor of
relativity from photon the measure of
time that front curtain experiences
again I'm experiences as is zero right
or they just it's infinity so this is
where this picture comes in and it's
partly this thing I was saying it's very
general
it's very very very boring era because
it's not so boring
because as far as they're concerned
about this final boundary so the photons
you got a future for them because the
boundary just running this life-size
version also said this boundary it's
just like anywhere else and so well what
does it just or doesn't find something
from the other side so the argument here
and it was a useful point of view I used
to play around with this a long time ago
looking gravitational waves and seeing
how people talk about the useful to
think that you couldn't imagine that
there was something on the other side
Oh my colleague Paul Todd who was a
student of mine at one time retired like
seven year students in mine and their
attack is rather
so anyway his idea it was had a lot of
trouble trying to characterize what the
geometry was like in order for this
things are working well I come to this
point of view was well before I come to
that look just chill with us all going
there's nothing unconventional about
what I sing here I should say this is
okay for my sake this picture well they
do have trouble with on the other hand
is what I say next
and this is to say what is on the other
side here there is something must hear
before that well what I'm saying is
there was another now you see what city
on well I considered in the entire
history of what we think of as our
universe now this isn't our history is
any you know I look sure to make sure
that our big memory was the conformal
continuation of the remote future of a
previous ear and our remote future will
be the continuation of that will be the
big bang on the next year now you see
one of their attractions about this is I
don't need inflation that's one of the
big attractions because rather than
tucking this exponential expansion
remember that picture was to show the
remote future look rather like that and
it does in some way in inflation
certainly tries to making and I'm saying
it's not touching there that actually
was this previous Eon and it wasn't
inflation of course by this
in photography oh that song it really
was I should give credit to Donatello
[Music]
you have an idea rather like this before
I did a certain model Justin malaria so
it's just not the same as this if he
certainly had this idea of having so
that idea was not making now one
convince you that this is not such a bad
idea for the big belly as well I still
you see neither huge constraint and this
gives you a huge constraint let me make
one point and that says you might say
well the Big Bang doesn't much like
inflation but you see that's like the
remote future this is very cold and very
and thence very rarefied where's this is
very dense and very hot how different
could they be when you see when you do
the conformal thing when you squash down
distances you increase energies and
temperatures you increase the densities
and you increase the energies and
temperatures conformity it's completely
equivalent if you stretch it out again
they're old and very rarefied and so if
the conformal so that's basically it
makes a lot of sense but to make this
thing the point I tried to make for a
long time is that make someone but I'm
saying roughly speaking it's telling us
that things get more and more round and
it's time goes up not to speaking so
that's that's the entropy the entropy is
going up sort of measure a prime
now suppose I'm gonna tell you the same
thing in a different way it goes up into
the future it goes down into the so if
you go back and back and back in time
the entropy goes down and down and down
the DA and so you think's more less and
less random as you go now what's the
best piece of evidence that the Big Bang
was there at all well it's this thing
called the microwave background coming
to us this is something in my title
actually did you see in me is the cosmic
microwave background title now this year
in B this is radiation coming to us in
all directions and one of the most
striking features of this radiation is
inspection this is the different
frequencies here and the different
entities this way we find this curve and
this curve is what's called very very
close to what's called a plank these
bars but the error bars are all
magnified manufacture of 500 so if you
put them to scale there would be all
happy mean client in this picture now
this is what you see in this microwave
background what it's telling you in this
micro Bank room is saying you're looking
at where the plaque curve is a statement
of maximum entropy
it's called blackbody radiation but it
means you were looking at maximum
integer
I always regarded this is the you're
going down and down and down it's going
down and down the down was it wise the
maximum signature
well the argument basically is simply
this I must say then the universe was
expanding and so something rather but
that's not the answer I just thought he
was not the answer it doesn't matter why
I was so so special in the other stages
now you see what was special about it
was not what you're looking at here what
you're looking at in this night
the radiation is radiation and matter
it's expanding looking at maximum
entropy of like the radiation and the
matter which isn't some randomized
together what you're not seeing in that
radiation is gravity and the thing is
about the early stage and this is always
struck is an absolutely key point that
seem to be ignored by cost money just as
far as I can tell is this facts knowing
you see here I have a cartoon of entropy
increasing here we have a gas in the box
and you might imagine that you tried to
pass some trap to get gas in that
interest more region in the corner here
and then you release it and it spreads
are the uniformity is also a statement
of large entropy entropy is going out it
suppose you have a lot of gravitating
bodies in a galactic scale box or
something well then will gravitate and
they were started mention they produce
black holes and they produce a black
hole the entropy shoots up anonymously
so entropy is going up in both pictures
they look very different what we see is
uniformity all over the sky that's a
very strong feature of the microwave
background is very very uniform aren't
you've corrected for the Earth's motion
through it you see something which is
uniform to about one part of 19,000 so
very very slightly changes in the
temperature but very small very uniform
so that's consistent with that picture
and also with this picture so what
you're seeing is a combination of those
two pictures that's what the early
universe was like this is much gravity's
concern it's a very very low entropy
state so this always struck me is a huge
puzzle you've got in the universe we
know this huge imbalance right at the
beginning and inflation doesn't do
anything to sort it out right in the
beginning when gravity was not
thermalized it was very special
everything else was pretty well as a
next
and just a support importance of this
you see like what's that depends on the
Sun and not weaken anything because the
energy coming in the difference is hot
and the dark sky is cold the top means
energy high energy photons and therefore
a smaller number of them carrying the
same energy that much much anymore going
totally Trang's energy these are much
lower frequency than these little energy
individually that means much more of
them yeah that's more room for the
entropy their entropy is carried away
that's what it's a point made by
Schrodinger he got into trouble and
other people because they so the point
is that you have a hotspot in a dark sky
and that's an entropy imbalance which we
live on and that's exactly the universe
which starts off in this very particular
way we should scheme at mine but you can
ensure that you have well there's a
problem that you might think about yeah
of course you've got a cyclic model and
you say well okay the entropy is going
up and up and up and up and up and up
and up and up how many exactly what they
she was going up water a good worried me
really I have to say I thought all sorts
of wrong things first and then I thought
the following point which some people
will say is wrong too but you've got to
have something it's this problem or not
even if it's this moment doesn't have
something which is that the entropy well
where is the entropy of our current
universe well most of it saying well the
blackbody radiation
coming in is very very high which is
it's nothing compared with the entropy
black holes the entropy and black holes
today right now is completely utterly
dominated by citizen same sentence wrong
the entropy in our universe right now
it's completely dominated by the entropy
in black holes so it's in the black
holes and what happens the black holes
well they evaporate away I'm Hawking
evaporation oh you run into this little
bit of problem
Hawking vs. 14 originally put forward
the idea of the radiation and so on and
he argued that information is lost in
black holes and I think he was right but
later on well it took a different view
for various reasons and its enormous
with a huge supermassive black hole
dominating everything around what was I
gonna say yes you have to to your
permission so this means your definition
of entropy when you start to define
entropy you take into consideration all
the degrees of bigger picture around but
once you've lost degrees of freedom in
the black hole that means you have to be
normal
introducing do I take those into
consideration okay then the entropy is
going up let me say though there's no
use to me anymore
and it comes walloping down you're not
violating the second law but you are
saying well my own definition of entropy
is no good anymore I'll take a new one
this is exactly what works and so you do
have a scheme which makes sense because
every time not actually at the crossover
from one to the next a little bit before
it you have to say well you have to say
the entropy really has got bound to the
value only the question is the one you
know considering you want to use that
slightly subtle this point and I think
it works all these things need to be
gone into you also need to have some
mathematics to describe the situation I
won't go into this year that's right
I've got time that you can what you do
is you see this is the previous Eon and
the next next neon and you've got a
metric here and I'll mention here yeah
and then you have to have a metric which
the bandage metric which covers both
regions and you have these conformal
factors which match I'm not going to go
into all this but I say that there are
equations we have to solve them all well
to make it make sense
I'll make a point though you see you
have degrees of freedom in the
gravitational waves yes
see I used to lecture about this for a
long time they're quite happy that
nobody would ever disprove it this is
the government say it's an icy mess the
first thing I thought of was well what's
the most violent thing I could imagine
it could be happy well the Big Bang is
pretty bad
forget about that for the moment what's
the next most violent thing well galaxy
has this supermassive black hole
four million times the mass of the Sun
we are on a collision course with the
Andromeda galaxy of ingenuity and we're
going to whack into it in a few
thousands of years and it's got a black
hole in its center I forget where
there's 20 times as big as ours or
quality time maybe say twenty let's say
it's a lot bigger than ours
I don't know they won't hit each other
in this condition stay with each other
and eventually spiral into each other it
will be extremely violent and signals
this is the sort of picture I have here
we have black holes coming together and
they I mean imagine several you see in a
cluster of galaxies drama dance and same
clusters we are but within a cluster
these black holes will start working and
eat into each other and ultimately there
will be one survivor one victor whatever
you call it in the end which dominates
four galaxies and there just sits there
swallowing up stars
gulping the moment it is hungry and so
on but before that there will be various
explosions were
gravitational waves go out they meet the
crossover surface you see the light
curves don't make sense
couple of microphones right up the edge
and they meet this crossover surface and
then what happens on the other side well
you know that's we have some of the
equations what you see is that the
gravity
the reason get killed off by the way the
conformal factor works that's a
technical detail which you have to look
at and what you see is these degrees of
freedom as gravity it killed off and the
information goes into the newly created
dark matter
so in this scheme that matter has to be
created in each junction between these
you know the next and since it's being
created and I don't want to build that
over here not sorry on decay away and so
during the course of it decays away well
I think I may have talked about this
sort of thing here before yeah I think
there are some observational tests in
terms of decaying but let's not talk
about that
why not talk about yeah tests I should
say CTC is the conformal cyclic
cosmology model which I'll be talking
about here and these are - yes there are
several other tests you could think of
the - now that I'm talking about here
one is these collisions between black
holes and they go out and they form
these rings that we we see you have to
imagine on this yeah this is the Big
Bang surface here this subsequent
surface is what's for last scattering or
well there's several things it's all in
the same place pretty well in this
picture point new decoupling service and
what you actually look back at when you
receive this microwave background it's
the second service and there's a little
gap between this rotational radiation
and this
[Laughter]
this is what there is a single back home
now what happens to all that radiation
but it's sort of remember the edge of
the picture does it finally just the
Scourge or it's mostly in the form of
photons photons come straight through
there may be neutrinos now things but
mostly
photons will come straight through until
they hit this next service now that is
another test I want to show you see
actually I was having discussions with
Christophe Meisner who's my polish
colleague precise test of the Rings
measurement and then they started
looking at these because I'm gonna show
you the list of figures here explain
some of these things and why it's rather
remarkable because well first of all
you've got to imagine though it's what's
remarkable about that you see these are
looking at ringless now let me have a
rather than scrappy picture of rings it
was my scrappy picture what they look at
is rings like that with our zero is the
in our one I think it's the radius of
the inner ring and R 2 is the radius of
the other ring and the epsilon is the
diameter ring so R 2 minus R 1 is
epsilon now they were looking at
different in that they were measuring
the increase of temperature
[Music]
[Music]
thank you okay so we're looking at rings
with different inner radius difference
and what they were trying to look at was
the difference it's with the temperature
so positive temperature would be as if
you increase the temperature though yeah
and that's what you would expect for the
Rings I just told me that you about the
black hole collisions so that was fun
they were sort of initially looking for
but there's something else which is what
they found is women in a one was a
bigger temperature but meows right and
if this is just rough pictures for the
air please two values of r and epsilon
that is when they found zeros so what
that means is when you look at these
rings for those particular husband in
radii and epsilon 0 what they do is they
look at
the problem is always they say you look
if you're trying to do cosmology but
they only got one universe so you can't
very well do experiments by making other
universe what some people trying to
because we've only got the one
so what people do is a particular thing
which is bad but you have to do it this
way or else nobody will look at you
and what you basically do you work out
what's this thing called a fire spectrum
and I forget what I showed you this
before it's one of the great successes
in cosmology is that at least when you
start that I should say that you're
looking at measuring a balloon and that
balloon vibrates oscillates in different
ways and there's one of the ways it's
sort of telling it makes if you like
which is the L value and the different
ways it can oscillate within that
particular vibrational speed is the M
value what you do is you take this is
the end of the L value here and if you
pick that from the actual universe and
then you can randomize the other
parameters so that's what they do you
seem to make a fix guy make sure that
he's got the right L values so that's
this curve that we see and then HR be
proud of this code right correctly
because it does the data fits the
expectations from very extremely well
doesn't tell me much about inflation or
sometimes the inflation is thing it does
it really what it tells you is what's
going on between the Big Bang or the end
of inflation if you like if inflation
what's there from the Big Bang to the
surface you see the last scattering
circuits or something that's about
380,000 years and the physics there is
very well understood this is what we
really know what's going on and you get
this very nice picture which puts pretty
well the beginning stuff is not too good
because you don't have quite so know
what's happening in the beginning let us
say this is long and big angles and
there's a small angle if you're looking
at the fine detail you get this very
precise picture that demand actually
well for two reasons one is that you see
when these people my colleagues in
working on these figures what they do is
they take a thousand of these fix cars
those fixed cars all have me no spectrum
picture all the things guys have the
stage in correction that's your doctor
louder very and the further ocular
picture you get you've got more
parameter Barry and those parameters the
M values as they call you can render
brandeis them so you first of all look
this is 1000 simulations and within that
thousand simulations how many of those
exceeded what you see in the real sky
and the answer is that for these
particular parameter values
none whatsoever so then in the actual
sky you see an amount of increase of
temperature in which in other words
decreases what they call negative
because it's going down as you go out so
hotter in the middle and decaying out
this way and they didn't see a single
one in there flowers and simulations and
what I'm imagining is is you have uh
something with a bump like this in
temperature and your ring cuts this
thing on the slope ok so that's what
they seem to see and well the sentencer
Physical Review Letters got rejected
various reasons but one of the points
people made I think I look elsewhere
which is justification that is to say we
did although I should say when I
realized what they were seeing and why
you had such a strong effect it seems to
me you must be looking at holding points
that is the thing which I was just
trying to describe here all this energy
mass energy in that black hole deposited
just underneath the surface here and
then it spreads out from here to here
and the actual amount of that spread is
what is four degrees in the sky which is
just about the size of these rings here
and that's where you see this effect now
if a spread was less than that
it would have to be something which
happened within this region between
where the physics is so well understood
it's hard to see a lot of things field
banging a little with that doesn't make
sense maybe it could have been run at
the Big Bang
that's that's where you get thinking
about this a scale okay that would make
sense but what about suppose inflation
is there when you see normally people
would think that anything like this and
then it will be much bigger spring so
it's basically inflationary picture it's
far far bigger effect it's not four
degrees in the sky it could be anything
much much huger than that so it's hard
to see how it could be inflation in an
inflationary moment unless it was
looking very very end
now that's what they call the graceful
exit theory how'd you get rid of
infection have you turn it off it's a
big challenge for a patient because you
can't do it all over the universe all at
once it's going to turn off yeah it's
going to turn off in such a way I'm sure
somebody will come up with an
explanation in the inflation but for the
moment it's not something that it's
expected at all then I don't see how
inflation is going to do it okay but
then people said well it's a look
elsewhere effect you were looking at
that so the probability is not so bad
so the value and a whole lot more well
one one thousand in 10,000 simulations
now you can subtract one thousand from
that because that's what we used to fix
our attention on these particular points
now what do you see well you do see a
couple of you see a one on the two so
it's not quite zero but at least it
tells you to work hard and work on the
probability because this means that out
of the 9,000 simulations well actually I
should say in some sense is 18,000
because you're looking at two cents a
day to one where you have a small effect
yeah yeah
so you could say you're doing a
simulation for that one in this
simulation for this one that's okay it
was however you do the calculation but
this would be a genuine effects and not
a random effect the probability from now
this is the Collinson right at the end
the probability of that unlikeliness if
you only see it I mean this should be a
a random effect the problem is it's a
random effect this is about
well the properties of a genuine effect
is 99.9 80 percent so it gives you a
very strong confidence that this is a
real effect more than order of magnitude
greater than the temperature
fluctuations you see in the sky in
normal way so there's something really
there and it needs to be explained and
it's it can be explained by it being all
key points maybe it's something else
then the name will have to be changed to
something else I hope to see within the
current cosmology excluding the one I
just been showing you I can't see any
model which explains these
[Applause]
very much unlike typical finals here at
UCSD we're gonna have questions for the
instructor followed by delicious
pressure actually you're applying to
UCSD so well past microphones are
roaming people that have questions a
couple of seconds I'll ask the question
while I'm walking around looking for
volunteers make them so the other thing
to get that's hard to get rid of in
science or cosmology or magnetic fields
I'll say something about what a magnetic
field would do in this that's my
question yes well that's something I but
you can actually see where they are
discussed and I should say that the
spread out that I was giving you yeah is
about up to about eight times the DA we
move you see the movement is only about
a half a degree because you're looking
at something with a spread so you're
looking at something which you might
think it's very big now one of these
points came about because
[Music]
[Music]
because if they were you earlier
the necessity for very special
conditions origin or else you would end
up with a mess when you extrapolate it
back yes now you're saying there are
some odd things going on at the origin
can you connect these yes one of the
main arguments for them is really going
to here was a way of characterizing
particular I said low entropy in the
very early universe and I used to sell
it we'll have you talked about that well
I'm saying degrees of freedom are not
excited in the early universe and the
foundation of ease of freedom are
characterized by the presence of fire
curvature that's a kind of curvature
which you see conformal character images
and you could say that a conformal
culture is the gravitational field
saying it but my colleague pulls hard
and suggested well you could say that
the condition is that you can extend the
Big Bang in a conformal picture to
something before it so where as I was
saying that like to think there's
something afterwards when you get closer
to Big Bang temperatures get so high
that all particles are in effect
massless because the the mass of the
particles becomes irrelevant and the
energy also all in their motions they
might be massless so that's how make
sense of it at the early universe now
they would say well does the so this was
brought our way of saying
that is if there was like this then it
has to be the case in this big and small
it seems to have some relation to that
because that's what you get so whether
there's a time with that possibly but
the trouble I have with things like the
strings and ends so they require these
extra dimensions which which so on the
other hand crystal
his colleague is also powerful
physicists and he likes playing around
with some of these supersymmetry models
and there was something very curious
about some of these models is that they
do suppress the creation of conformal
anomalies so I talking about globally
about conformal symmetry and all that
but you do have problem with auto
mechanics and component conformal
transformations and if you're going to
make sense of this picture and with some
of these theories it turns out that you
don't this looks like an amazing
coincidence because what it all means
but I suspect it does have a big impact
on particle physics at some stage that's
terrific
of course when people are looking for
these mysterious rings in the sky some
of the people who are looking for them
are looking for contact points between
parallel universes so they are
observational be looking for something
very similar even though your concept is
entirely different if you care to
address that but my question actually
has to do with the lopping off of 150
zeroes in the scaling when you move from
one universe one Eon to the next one and
that is that don't you need for there to
be dissipation well first off put two
possum
proton decay in order to eliminate
reference frames because you can't do
this if there's a witness
yes because okay if you've got quarks
and if you've got clocks they know the
time and so it doesn't make sense
so I'm postulated that there is called a
speed art
this is not decay of particles into into
this massive ones because we don't know
where to go
he knows just conceivable the one with a
personal memory that's still consistent
so the argument is that the max over
huge time skills needs to fade out now
there is it's not such a stupid
suggestion because see one of the first
things that particle physicists do when
they start to classify particles is they
classify them very group and they
consider these things called Casimir
operators and there are two Casimir
operators one is the mass and one is the
spin and the Casimir operators have the
character that they commute with
everything else which means that they
are absolutely constant so it is hard to
make the mass fade out and then you will
be discussing your operations and you
find that it's more like an extremely
strong theoretical argument so I take a
couple more questions before breaking as
all good theoreticians need for coffee
absolutely marvelous talk other non
physicists let me ask you really now
your question you're suggesting we have
to wait around for a googol of years for
the next but what are the chances of
that is it possible the Big Bang kept
them more often than that even though
you can have to wait around for these
operations well you see waiting around
becomes lots of boring because if you
haven't got a mass you don't get bored
the waiting is time so you have to think
it's not that many years from the
controlling perspective so you have to
you have to take a view at the time
because it's not really the important
thing and then these conformal map
serial pictures and it's just there I
agree that it's hard to get your mind
around but once the mass is fades of the
way the nice fade out is something which
happens I started quite by the time to
get to the crossover it actually becomes
here that's the picture I think there
was more of your question which is about
traffic argument well there was a
question you see
things like that and he thought maybe
the constant of nature would get shut
about this time at least I was different
and you have that problem here as well
it might be that in one yeon the
constants of nature some value in the
next one they're different and where
they suitable for conscious beings to be
around values for those constants that
would be one point of view I'm not at
all happy with that point of view I
would prefer it's not such a surprise
but the point I did want to make is one
little bit of evidence but these numbers
don't change huge this has to do with
when you see we're about here people I
got around here and you can see when do
black holes start to run in each into
each other what's somewhere around here
and that means that in the rings that we
see nothing things I've sorted about
here not holding for the actual rings
there's a maximum size that can get to
which is about 40 degrees across the sky
and that is from the very very earliest
black hole collisions that you can
imagine
for us the size of these struggles can
get to is and you see some which are
pretty big like that so they gets us
something almost that big you don't see
them any bigger which seems to me to be
an indication so thank you again for
coming here and speaking with us I
confess my mathematic background is not
as advanced as to be able to fully
appreciate the expansion and compression
but I am curious if we were to almost
take take a page out of the earlier days
with a Planck and Einstein I imagine an
indestructible demon with infinite
powers of observation you know washing
it toward the end of the universe as you
were getting closer and closer to the
boundary between one universe and the
next Oh what would we see you of course
see these explosions from occasionally
as these separate but eventually like a
Fermi gas masters particles floating
around what brings it from that darkness
into a sudden explodes
yeah I agree it's worth thinking about
it and I didn't know so somebody was
building this indestructible space and
could construct this container
to go back right the way around to
measure the scale so the argument would
be you just couldn't have maybe our
friends at biology can help invent such
a being
[Applause]